l'ate
je vais te trouver un autre test
ouah
il y aurait pas un sérieux danger
d'incendié avec tout ça je n'avais
jamais vu sous cet angle là tout vous
sortez tous ces objets dans la vie tu
sais y'a des tas de trucs qu'on traîne
avec j'en sais pas pourquoi terme pour
sa collection amassée
c'est ça abbas et je suis comme ça moi
aussi
jamas au comment tu t'appelles plus de
ces mots nar s'attend pas à ce qu'il te
répondre il va falloir que je lui coûter
nouvelle bouche
ça va tout va bien ça va ça va ça va
arriver de temps en temps de mes mises
la dernière fois c'était à lui je suis
resté par terre pendant trois jours
c'est pas grave c'est pour ça que j'ai
toujours un sandwich à la mortadelle
dans ma poche
thomas avoue j'ai une intolérance à la
mortadelle tu sais pas ce que tu loupes